there's two field goals i know yo kenny
this is gonna decide hong kong
first round is what i'm saying look at
the air time that he has in there
first dump
if zach levine didn't do that last week
in the lay-up
if he didn't do that last week in the
league three go get that
it was it was impressive but he made it
look too easy
that's a 10. that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm talking about what these guys that's
a windmill one hand windmill cost
yeah slowing in the air that's a 10.
yeah derek jones jr did this last year
and he got a nine
nine but this is this year and this is
dominique's butt
[Music]
who else is over there giving bad marks
out
jason richardson john smith
he's going to the tracy mcgrady jersey
uh big fan of the 2000
slam dunk competition i got a question
for you kenny after this dump
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
when he got out there he felt something
i don't i didn't have that luxury
that's why i'm mad at dominique because
i did eight original dunks he did five
the same though
ain't got 50s on side ducks this right
here was nice
oh he put his head by the rim uh i mean
he put his he kissed
it
he almost kissed it he almost kissed it
oh this is
it i want to put a mouthpiece
[Applause]
lift it up